So, so we're talking about how we can't, you know, there's nothing to do.
So our birthday this year, cause today is Wednesday. It's 26.
My actual birthday yesterday was Janice's birthday. And we're just like,
this is what we do now. The birthday is kind of just to be with you, the fans,
because everything else is fricking closed every year.
We just have a birthday episode because our birthdays are so close together.
This is our combined 40th birthday. Right. Um,
what are we going to do for it this year? During the pandemic,
we got to figure something out. What do you want to do? Um,
you want to have a baby Q and a,
we'll just call it a baby queue because you know, baby, we will do a baby.
We could do that. Or, um, you want to hang out with, um,
vetted TIAs parade in central park and talk about social justice issues.
We could do that. Yeah, we could do that. Why don't we just,
or we could just carry stuff, carry briefcases of equipment with pinky here.
We can do that. Yeah. Well, why or why don't we just celebrate Kamala Harris?
You know, I, I didn't realize how selfish we were being.
This is a historic time for this country. We're an Indian,
African American or whatever her father she's after made Hampshire make it,
but that makes her an African-American. Yeah. Whatever her dad's.
Her dad is Indian and her mom is Jamaica. Our dad is Jamaica. Her mom is Indian.
So therefore she is the first African-American vice presidential candidate.
That's just the country limit. I'm not, I'm just saying what it is.
It is what it is. But, um, we are,
we being selfish by celebrating our birthdays on such a historic occasion where
really this episode should be about,
should we give our birthdays to black people? Yeah. Yeah. I forgot the kid.
Trevor Wallace was on the Gramercy theater show and he sold out two shows and
it's just, yeah, he just, Trevor Wallace just looks like me if I got Corona,
because look, look at, look at the, what we did though.
And that was the first time we worked with Becky. That's what it is.
There's Zach ISIS. Remember Zach ISIS members, Zach. I mean,
we've come a long way. I mean, look at that crowd. It's unbelievable.
And I think that I shouldn't have been wearing that sweater was too small.
For me, but who cares? Creekstone?
It doesn't matter. Lookout jacked. I was there.
I was working out then there was gyms open.
I was a real strong kid at that moment. Yeah. I mean, I was a kid that like,
if you had a snap and right, you can put me down, but if I got ahold of ya,
yeah, I'm definitely gonna bite.
It's good to just bite if I get close to bite and I don't know why I decided to
wear shoes that night, but I wanted to be a grownup. I had a,
my show is like almost dead when this happened. I remember the show was,
I remember the show was at midnight and I almost passed out because it was too,
I was too sleepy and that girl comes to every show. Yeah. Um, yeah, I mean,
yeah.
Happy birthday to you. Happy birthday to you.
[inaudible].
Make sure you rate, review us, subscribe, turn on your notifications,
get jiggy with it and go to patron.com/bay Ridge boys, where things get really.
Wild.